[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à evian sous les fenêtres de l'hôtel du
parc la tempête du lac s'est apaisée
symbole peut-être est tour à tour
belkacem krim et la délégation fln louis
joxe et la délégation française se sont
encore une fois retrouvée mais cette
fois pour conclure
des heures qui passent trop lentement au
gré des journalistes qui assiège la
porte et soudain après douze jours de
discussions serrées la salle des
délibérations se retrouvent silencieux
et vite pendant que les hélicoptères
remporte au dessus du lac la délégation
algérienne les ministres français
quittent l'hôtel les sourires annonce
qu'une grandeur attendu depuis plus de
sept ans a sonné
et le soir même à les viser le général
de gaulle pouvait annoncer aux foules
française la conclusion du cessez le feu
en algérie
les dispositions adoptées
pour que les populations
il dispose de vesta
la perspective qui s'ouvre sur
l'avènement d'une algérie indépendante
coopérant étroitement avec nous
satisfont la raison de la forme ce qui
va être
entreprise pour tirer d'une lui
déplorable les chances d'un avenir fico
est dû au peuple français car c'est lui
qui
par son beau sens
sa solidité
sa confiance
constamment témoigner à qui porte la
charge de conduire l'état et la nation a
permis que mûrissent puis aboutisse la
solution
le général de gaulle annonce est ainsi
de cessez le feu le président du gpk
monsieur ben raide à qui en avait fait
l'annoncé du côté fln était porté en
triomphe à la haine de tunis 1100
d'arqués pour gagner rabat où il
accueillerait benbella libéré
dans alger à demi paralysé par des
grèves une sorte de grand silence s'est
appesanti ces derniers jours les six
victimes de ben aknoun six dirigeants
des centres sociaux parmi lesquels
l'écrivain mouloud feraoun ont été
inhumés devant leurs cercueils 2
ministre monsieur guillaume à hebei ont
rappelé leur action et apporté l'hommage
du gouvernement
[Musique]
dans le centre de la ville où
l'abattement semble avoir succédé à
l'anxiété des derniers jours les
consignes de grève générale d'année aux
européens ont vidé les rues seul sur les
places et dans les rues semé de chicanes
et des barrages les éléments de l'armée
contrôle d'une circulation réduite à
zéro
les autobus sont restés au garage les
magasins sont fermés les ateliers
gardent leur portes closes un silence
pesant règne
réprobation inquiétudes réflexion il y a
de tout dans ce silence et même
peut-être de l'espérance
c'est un ami que la france a reçu en la
personne de monsieur françois tombalbaye
président de la république et chef du
gouvernement du tchad au cours d'une
visite de trois jours commençaient avait
visé par un entretien avec le général de
gaulle
[Musique]
paris a salué sur les champs elysées ce
jeune chef d'état de 43 ans au moment où
il allait se recueillir sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu
monsieur françois tombalbaye et le 9e
des chefs d'état de l'afrique
d'expression française que la france ait
reçu depuis l'accession de leur pays à
l'indépendance en 1960 il est aussi
celui qui a pu dire mon pays a été le
premier a rallié la france libre en 1940
je vient confirmer cette amitié
hu
à genève la conférence ou plutôt le
comité du désarmement s'est ouvert avec
seulement 17 de ses participants sur 18
une place en effet resté vide celle de
la france dont le scepticisme est du
reste connu quant aux chances possibles
d'une telle conférence
dès les premières réunions il semble
bien du reste que les points de vue
américain et russe se soient confirmés
fondamentalement inconciliables il reste
comme voici quinze ans séparés par la
question capitale du contrôle
[Musique]
spectacle insolite sur la plage de
cannes que n'aurait pas imaginé les
familiers de la croisette l'ancien
paquebot français de grass devenu
italien sous le nom de venezuela s'est
échoué à 200 mètres du rivage les 190
passagers sont sains et saufs mais les
opérations de renflouement se révèle
délicate et le sort du navire de 18
mille tonnes restent des plus incertains
[Musique]
voici exactement 30 ans le monde entier
suivait avec une attention horrifié les
développements d'un drame affreux
l'enfant de charles lindbergh qui était
l'idole des foules depuis sa traversée
de l'atlantique
un bébé de 20 mois avait été enlevé dans
son berceau au premier étage de la villa
que ses parents habitaient à la campagne
le kidnappeur avait en descendant cassé
l'échelle dont il s'était servi lundi ce
devait servir plus tard la demande d'une
rançon de 50 mille dollars appuyé sur
l'envoi de pièces d'habillement du bébé
fut discutée par un étrange personnage
le docteur condom qui devait plus tard
assuré reconnaître la voix de son
correspondant anonyme puis on retrouva
le bébé est mort il avait dû tomber
quand l'échelle c'est theron
plus tard un billet de la rançon remis à
un poste d'essence mis la police sur la
trace d'un certain richard hoffman
charpentier en perpétuelle chômage qu'on
arrête à la maison qu'ils habitaient fut
soumise à une perquisition minutieuse et
le garage qui lui servait d'atelier
complètement disséqués
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on y retrouva dans un bidon une partie
de la rançon les numéros des billets
correspondait à la liste établie par la
banque au moment de leur remise aux
kidnappeurs hoffman allaient-ils avoué
nom
et au palais de justice de flemington
s'ouvrit deux ans et demi après
l'enlèvement
ce qu'on appela alors le procès du
siècle 300 journalistes et radio
reporters étaient venus du monde entier
le procès devait durer trente deux jours
pendant lesquels hawkman tint tête aux
attaques du procureur
[Musique]
mais les indices semblaient convaincant
hoffmann fut condamné à mort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en voyant patiner le jeune canadien
donald jackson tous les concurrents des
championnats du monde à prague on tue
des complexes dans ces conditions
jackson était certain de remporter le
titre
ce qu'il a réussi avec beaucoup de brio
bien que les juges n'aient pas eu pour
lui des regards très tendre
ce n'est pas là le seul titre de
champion du monde décerné au canada en
couple léger inec qui sont canadiens eux
aussi bien que leurs noms ne l'indiquent
pas ont effectué la meilleure exhibition
et pourtant leurs numéros ne s'est pas
passé sans accroc
le public qui connaît les difficultés du
patinage ne leur en tient pas rigueur
le et la fin de leur exhibition méritait
bien qu'on leur attribue le titre de
champion du monde
[Musique]
0 0 c'était le score à la mi temps du
match monaco nîmes les nîmois en maillot
légèrement plus foncé que les
monégasques ont bien du mal à prouver
qu'ils sont les candidat numéro un au
titre de champion de france de football
de fait monaco comme en ce moment même
le plus souvent l'offensive mais et tout
cela est mièvre étriqué bref sans grande
est un sel comme ce tir de l'ailier
gauche qu'aux
monaco finit cependant par marquer un
but à un quart d'heure de la fin du
match j'ai dû changer la face des choses
le match soit tout à coup de la
grisaille et on assiste à un véritable
spectacle sportif qui ne fait cependant
pas tremblé deux passions les
spectateurs dans les tribunes
les nîmois attaque avec beaucoup de
réalisme un certain brio et aussi un peu
de réussite
résultat il marque un but eux aussi
juste à temps pour obtenir un match nul
somme toute assez équipés
si vous aimez la neige si vous ne savez
pas vous tenir sur des skis et si vous
appréciez la vitesse alors fait du spic
les scouts qui utilisent désormais les
canadiens ce cas la fois un traîneau
maïak est un acte
nouveaux vaisseaux des neiges
al'avantage de se déplacer à la vitesse
d'une voiture de course plus de 160 à
l'heure avec le bruit évidemment ça
manque peut-être un peu de poésie
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]